We've heard really stupid arguments from climate
science deniers on Fox News before.
That's nothing new.
We've heard, oh, it's cold in winter in North
Dakota.
Clearly there's no climate change.
We've heard, oh, plants breathe carbon dioxide.
So more of it must be good.
We've heard, oh, a senator threw a snowball
in the Senate in winter.
Climate change clearly is fake, but they are
now starting to actually get angry and frustrated
on Fox News that all these stupid liberals
actually believe climate change as a problem
or better said, except the science on the
issue of climate change.
Check out this totally unintelligible and
quite frankly, moronic rant from Pete Hegseth
on Fox News.
The biggest national security threat according
to Bernie Sanders is climate change.
The left says it all the time.
This is what they believe in is their religion.
They want to fight the weather.
Uh, the rest of us want to deal with real
threats that want to take away our freedoms.
And in re think about four years ago, what
was that?
2015 isis was still, uh, you know, this was
during Obama's term, isis was still a huge
problem.
The caliph, it was their president Trump ran
on destroying isis, which he did to their
physical caliphate.
Now there's remnants that we need to be concerned
about today that's taking on a real threat
directly.
Uh, w whether it's hot or cold, the enemy
is here as far as liberals are concerned and
it's all control for them.
That's why climate change is the perfect enemy.
They get to control your life, to deal with
it, no matter what's happening.
Can you imagine being so out of touch with
reality that when you see the left wanting
to deal with climate change, a crisis today,
you think it's about liberals wanting to control
the lives of people?
Like can you imagine a dumber and less informed
take on this issue other than maybe climate
change is a hoax created by China?
Again, the weather versus climate trope surfaces,
again, this couldn't be more clear.
They are frustrated that the left understands
and believes and more importantly accepts
science.
They are mad that the left isn't falling for
their propaganda the way that many of their
own viewers have fallen for it.
They actually talk about belief in climate
change as if it's like belief in God.
You either have faith in it or you don't,
but there's no knowable objective reality.
And unfortunately for many Fox News viewers,
maybe God is more real than climate change
in terms of how they view this concept of
belief and faith in which is genuinely scary
and maybe a conversation for a different day.
But I actually think that the whole concept
of belief is a misnomer.
You can accept or not accept the science,
but belief and faith is actually irrelevant
to the reality.
We shouldn't let them use this language around
these issues because it blurs the lines between
belief in God and belief in science.
Science as a process.
You can accept it or not.
You can understand it or not, but it simply
is.
It is not pseudo religious in the way that
peaks Pete Hegseth is talking about.
Fox is mad that people accept empirical evidence
over Fox's anti-science propaganda.
That's fundamentally what this is about.
And listen, it's not just Bernie saying climate
change is a national security threat.
The Pentagon agrees, the military gets it.
We've talked about their assessments.
When the Pentagon says, we see this as such
a serious issue that we're going to lay out
a plan to fight climate change for national
security reasons.
It's real.
They are the extremists on Fox News.
When you look at acceptance of climate change
around the world, American right-wingers aren't
just out of place in the United States or
out of touch in the United States.
They're out of place around the world.
Even rightwing parties in most other countries
except climate change and human effect on
Climate Change, American conservatives are
truly the bizarre, crazy outliers who simply
won't and yes, Bernie's right.
Climate change is a national security threat,
but the anti science right-wingers are also
a security threat and we're fighting them
at the same time.
Let me know your thoughts.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
The show is on twitter@davidpakmanshowandihopethatyouwillfollowmeontwitchattwitch.tv
slash David Pakman where you can use your
Amazon prime subscription to
sign up to my channel with twitch prime.
It costs you nothing, but it counts as a paid
subscription for us
and I hope they'll do that.